y la decisión Del supremo sobre el
título 42 desencadenó esta reacción del
gobierno de Texas por qué
bueno porque principalmente hay
muchísimos problemas en cuanto a
logística y desafortunadamente no tienen
los medios económicos administrativos
poder plantear una solución inmediata al
Gran flujo de personas que están
tratando de cruzar la frontera desde
México hacia Estados Unidos y han visto
la militarización como una opción que yo
creo que es totalmente negativa para la
realidad que se está viviendo en la
frontera bueno Cuáles son en este
momento en su opinión las esperanzas de
los migrantes que ya no tienen certeza
de cómo será su proceso con el fin del
título 42 en duda
bueno Lamentablemente lo que estamos
mirando es que los migrantes van a tener
que buscar opciones adicionales cuando
no se les dé estas alternativas
jurídicas legales de poder solicitar el
asilo lo que principalmente les toca en
este momento será Ahora sí adentrarse a
áreas más peligrosas como sucedido en la
frontera sur de México por ejemplo que
también existe ya un muro militar que
tratan de cruzar Ahora cuando suceda lo
mismo en en Estados Unidos en Texas
principalmente luego será Arizona
seguramente tendremos más víctimas
tratando de cruzar la frontera en áreas
remotas bueno y sobre le quería
preguntar también si estas medidas serán
suficientes Más allá del mensaje de no
bienvenida que está dando Texas en estas
nuevas medidas adicionales podrán ser
suficiente para efectivamente persuadir
a los migrantes no va a ser suficiente
Nosotros hemos visto por ejemplo que en
el caso de los ecuatorianos
impuso una visa a Guatemala se impuso
una visa a México y eso no ha parado el
flujo de migrantes desde Ecuador igual
sucede con los migrantes de Venezuela de
otras nacionalidades el hecho de
militarizar la frontera no va a
desactivar el gran flujo de migrantes
que se está viviendo en en la frontera
sur de Estados Unidos al contrario lo
que estamos mirando es de que
lamentablemente las mafias los coyoteros
Los Traficantes van a ser su negocio
porque ahora les van a decir de que no
es tan fácil Entonces te cuesta un poco
más y vas a tener ir por rutas más
peligrosas